we are here with Anna and Elisa Anna
Eliza welcome to the show tell us a bit
about how are you feeling to see all
these great players here the world
champion is here in Bucharest how do you
feel about that
enthusiastic we are excited I'm quite
nervous actually it's my first time
going to such a big event and
we can't wait to see what happens next
when did you guys start playing chess
she's more integers than me yeah
and what would you say was your favorite
player as you were picking up chess
just because of the famous you know
YouTube the big husband chess
um it's hard to pick
um I'd say Chicago
okay yeah yeah I watch him on streams
sometimes very cool very cool and how
about the Queen's Gambit did you guys
see that show
I wanted to see it I think I'm going to
save her so it like twice about three
times I'm not sure it was amazing I
loved it yeah yeah and from this
tournament who is your favorite player
who do you think is going to win this
tournament I'm not sure we'll see what's
um what happens next honestly yeah yeah
um
I saw that he was like one phone up and
I was like oh this
we're getting a lot of nepo fans here
what is it about nepo what attracts you
to his playing style
um not sure what to say about that
I don't think I can say anything about
the playing style but I think he's a
good player I mean I saw that he was
against dingler and you know the world
championship and yeah
well guys thank you very much for
joining us Anna Eliza go enjoy the show
thank you